[Applause]
and hello florida hello florida
it's great to be with you and back at
the villages a rallying cry in a crucial
state florida is a must-win
election prize how many people here have
voted for president trump
how many people here have voted for
sleepy joe biden please history suggests
lou's here
and donald trump will likely lose the
white house
kamala will not be your first
female president look we're not going to
be a socialist nation we're not going to
have a socialist
president especially any female
socialist president we're not going to
have it we're not going to put up with
it
while the loyalty of the faithful is
unwavering
in a pandemic hot spot the president
knows his covered fighting credentials
could cost him get out and vote so
important
in stark contrast joe biden presented
his pandemic plan
with no crowds at all taking aim at the
president
acutely aware the covet crisis could
cement his lead
if this is a success
what's a failure look like we're more
than eight months into this crisis
and the president still doesn't have a
plan
he's given up he's quit on you he's quit
on your family
he's quit on america as donald trump
puts in more floridian face time
later today barack obama will drum up
support for democrats here
with just over a week to go the fight
for florida
is intensifying siobhan robbins sky news
florida